[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
28 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
Very good.
Very interested with the
main content of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We're moving away from
some of the shiny things,
sort of stepping
away from containers,
stepping away from App
Engine, going like, let's just
talk about VMs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
What is a virtual
machine, how do you
use them at Google,
how are better ours
than others, et cetera.
I think it's going to
be very interesting.
We're going to have--
what's his name?
MARK MANDEL: Scott Van
Woudenberg will be joining us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Scott
Van Woudenberg, yes.
And very good pronunciation
of that one, by the way.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
Thank you.
I've been working on my
pronunciation of names.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So yeah, we're
going to have him.
And then afterwards,
we're going to have
a question of the
week that comes
from one of our listeners,
Noam Franco, on--
MARK MANDEL: He's looking at
how we can connect data store
backups to BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, exactly.
So yeah, we're going to end that
doing that question of the week
at the end of the episode.
But before, we have a
cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We have this really great
new Udacity course from two
of our team members,
[? Kelsey ?] Hightower
and Carter Morgan, who have
done a communities online
Udacity course.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
And it is pretty amazing,
just because seeing
those two people working
together is really amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: They're
really, really fun.
But also basically it's going
to take you from the basics
to what is a
container and how do
you use them to generate--
well, to create microservices,
to then create
Kubernetes clusters,
and then deploy
microservices on them.
And basically
everything from scratch
to having your own microservices
running on the cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And best of all, it's free.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
yeah, absolutely.
It's absolutely free,
which is awesome.
And you can find a
link on our show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
It should be very
interesting to get done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm definitely going
to go through it.
Just-- I'm pretty sure
I know most of it.
I'm sure I will
learn some new stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
I think it's just
going to be fun to
see them presenting.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It sounds really, really good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So what do you think,
should we go talk to Scott?
MARK MANDEL: That sounds
like a great idea.
Let's talk about
virtual machines.
We are joined today by
Scott Van Woudenberg,
a PM on Compute Engine.
Scott, how are you doing today?
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: Good.
Doing well.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for having me on.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Before we get
stuck into what you
do at Google and the
products you work on,
why don't you tell us a little
about yourself and your role,
and all that sort of fun stuff.
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: Sure.
So I'm a product manager on
Google Compute Engine, which
is our Infrastructure as
a Service offering, which
is part of our broader
Google Cloud Platform.
Before Google, I was-- spent
about 16 years as a software
engineer and engineering
lead and manager, kind
of moving up the chain on the
engineering side of the house,
before I decided to switch
to product management.
So I came to Google in 2012
to be a PM on Computer Engine,
and I've been doing
it ever since.
Right around the time I
joined, like basically weeks
after-- like a few
weeks after I joined,
GCE was announced publicly
for the first time.
We kind of announced
our-- we called
it Limited Preview at the
time, but it's basically
our alpha launch at
that year's Google I/O.
So it's been a
very exciting ride
to ride the exponential
growth curve that we've
seen since we started,
and especially
since we GAed back in 2013.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, wonderful.
Well, thanks so
much for joining us.
Well, let's sort of start at the
most basic level that we can.
What is a virtual machine?
Like, I'm sure a
lot of our listeners
probably have a bit
of an idea, but I
think let's sort of go-- let's
go as simple as possible.
What is it?
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: Yeah.
So this is actually
kind of a tough question
to answer tersely, I
guess, or succinctly.
I spent a little time
kind of researching,
and took a look at what
Wikipedia had to say about it.
And kind of the most basic
definition I could find
was essentially
a virtual machine
is a software implementation of
a physical computer or server.
And then obviously
on Wikipedia it
was followed by a
few pages of fairly
low-level technical
detail on virtualization,
on hypervisors, on
paravirtualized devices,
on-- the list goes on and on.
And then along with
about two dozen reference
links down at the
bottom where you could
go read about more detail.
So I kind of stepped back
and thought about it.
And I think for the
purposes of this discussion
and just kind of for
cloud customers that
are looking at GCE or
comparing it against EC2
or just trying to
understand, maybe you
come from an App
Engine background
or you're a front-end
developer or-- depending
on where you're
coming from, it's
best just to kind think
of a VM as a trusted
ubiquitous computing
environment that
lets you decouple
the actual code that
runs from the hardware
that it runs on.
So think of it as
an abstraction layer
that is both secure
and ubiquitous,
which are kind of
the two things that
have made virtual machines
as popular as they are.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So like containers?
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG:
So containers
is actually a very-- that
is an excellent example
of a computing abstraction
that is not yet very secure.
And it is also not yet quite as
ubiquitous as virtual machines.
There will be a day
sometime down the road
where all of the security
issues get worked out,
like you can have complete
isolation between two
containers running
on the same host
and there'll be a very
secure, trusted sandbox
is kind of how we think
about these environments.
Computing abstraction layers
run in these sandboxes,
kind of like a JVM, kind of
like any interpreted language
has like a runtime environment.
And you know, that runtime
environment, that sandbox,
has to be proven to be
secure and impossible for one
container to break out of
that sandbox environment
to muck with the memory or other
area-- a different container's
environment, so
that you can have
a true multi-tenant
computing platform, which
is really what VMs gives you.
And the reason why
VMs is where it is
is because VMware started this
whole game 10, 12 years ago,
and has basically taken
the market by storm.
Back in the day before VMware,
everything ran just directly
on hardware.
And VMware added this
virtualization abstraction,
and it really took off.
But you know, it's
been secure-- they've
been finding all the
bugs and making sure
that it's secure for
the last 10, 12 years.
So containers is just kind of
at the beginning of that curve,
I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
[INAUDIBLE] security
concerns that you
were mentioning,
why could someone choose running
a VM using Google Compute
Engine rather than App Engine or
Kubernetes on Container Engine?
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: Yeah.
So I mean, the simplest answer
is because that's what-- like,
enterprise is anybody
coming to the cloud that
has existing workloads
either on prem or on AWS
or elsewhere, it's going
to be-- like a Compute
Engine or Infrastructure
as a Service is going
to be the most familiar
and probably most
like what they're
currently running,
especially enterprises
where most of them
are running on-- in their
data centers or in colo
environments or whatever.
They're probably using VMware.
The majority of them
are using VMware,
running virtual machines.
It's what they're familiar with.
This is basically
infrastructure is
going to be most customers'
on-ramp into the cloud.
And then once
they're on the cloud
and they're out of the business
of managing their own data
centers, like doing their three-
or five-year hardware refreshes
and dealing with all
that stuff, once they've
moved those applications
to the cloud,
onto GCE, from
there they'll then
be able to start
decomposing, rewriting,
rewriting components,
kind of splitting them out
into microservices
and taking advantage
of some of the other
really cool technologies
the cloud platform offers.
And not-- our cloud
platform obviously
offers some really amazing--
especially big data analytics,
machine learning, we've got a
ton of really amazing products
that abstract-- that
are built at a higher
level of abstraction.
Like, the machine learning is
basically an open source API,
so you don't actually
have to manage underlying
resources if you don't want to.
And Kubernetes is a great
example of that, where you just
write your code and write your
containers, like what you want
to implement in a
container, deploy it
as a microservice and
deploy dozens of other ones,
and they all start
talking to each other.
That's really kind
of the power there.
You don't have to think
about the hardware.
How much RAM, how many cores?
Like, am I using it efficiently?
All that other stuff.
You just stop thinking about it.
And that's the advantage
of moving up the stack.
But as far as getting workloads
into cloud, the first step,
the on-ramp is going to be GCE.
MARK MANDEL: Apart from
that sort of general on-ramp
to come into the cloud, are
there any particular use cases
you see that people
are like, oh,
VMs are just much
better for this
than, say, maybe
some of the more
shiny technologies out there?
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG:
So I think it really
kind of depends on what
people like to focus on.
At the end of the
day, virtual machines
give you absolute
control over every layer.
Every piece of the
software, you control.
You are the one that writes
all the code to do, like,
auto-scaling up and down,
and basically scaling
the number of VMs
that you have based
on the incoming
demand and capa--
and you know, requests per
second, whatever the metric is.
So really, for the very
sophisticated customers
or applications that
need control over
every aspect of
their application,
virtual machines
is probably going
to continue to be the go-to
product or go-to technology
for some of those.
There's also stuff like if you
have to run something like SQL
Server or something like a
third-party software package
that doesn't really have
a containerized version,
or that doesn't-- it's not
available to an App Engine app,
like a video encoding
library, for example.
Like, we have tons of
App Engine customers
that basically use App
Engine to orchestrate--
to do the front-end
serving, but then also
to orchestrate like kind
of transcoding workloads,
like media rendering,
that sort of thing.
And that's where they basically
break out of the App Engine
layer, use GAE, App
Engine Flex to run GCE VMs
but still manage my App Engine.
And those VMs, the only
thing that they're doing
is pulling videos
or audio off of SQ
and transcoding it, because
you can actually run
lib mmpeg and the other
transcoding libraries,
which are typically
written in C.
You can just run those in a
VM, where you can't really
run those in App Engine
without rewriting them
as a Python library or
something like that,
which is just too much work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
you just went exactly
through the architecture of
[INAUDIBLE] presented at Google
[INAUDIBLE] was exactly that.
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: Yep.
Yep.
I mean, it's a very
popular, very popular model.
And App Engine makes it really--
App Engine plus G App Engine
Flex make it really
easy to manage the VMs.
You still-- you know
that they're there,
but it handles all
of the orchestration
and so you don't have to.
And it just makes
it super simple.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I have
one more question regarding
this trend towards containers.
So you said that, for VMs, it's
like a very good place to when
you're doing my favorite
phrase, lift and shift,
to get started on the cloud.
Then some people
move to containers.
And what is your
opinion on this trend
towards serverless computing,
taking into account
that all your business
is selling servers?
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: So
serverless is-- I mean,
there's a couple
interpretations.
So one interpretation
of what that means
is I just write code.
I don't have to think about
the underlying deployment
orchestration.
I don't have to think
about how that code gets
scaled up and scaled down
to handle increased load,
like the diurnal cycles,
that sort of thing.
So it basically just
means that the product
or whatever it is
that I'm programming
against has abstracted away
the fact that under the covers
there's servers that are
connected over networks
and stuff like that.
So that's kind of
one interpretation.
Another one is
just, look, I just
have kind of like the cloud
functions model or the AWS
lambda model, where you're just
writing these little snippets
of code that you need to run
when some trigger comes in,
like-- I don't
know, like I've just
pushed a new request onto--
like an entry onto a task queue.
I want that to trigger a cloud
function to run and pull that
off the task queue and
do something to it,
and then push it back
onto a different task
queue or something.
And that's really where
something like cloud functions,
you really aren't even--
you're worried about even less.
You just write a
function, essentially
what ends up being like
a function in whatever
your favorite language is.
And then you hook it up--
you set up a trigger,
and then that function goes
off and does something which
may trigger other functions
to run, which gives you
this ability to kind of just
write individual functions,
hook them all together,
and you end up building
like these kind of crazy
complicated applications
that never have
to touch and never
have to even think about the
notion of even a container.
Like, it's completely abstracted
away even beyond that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So since we're talking
about Compute Engine
and you are pretty much
the expert on the topic,
what are your favorite
features of GCE?
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG:
So I think like a lot
of my favorite
features come from kind
of the underlying
flexible infrastructure
that we're built on.
So two of the best examples,
and my personal favorites,
are the permanent
billing that we have,
and then the automatic
sustained use discounts.
So permanent billing, you know,
most of the big hyperscale
cloud offerings right
now bill per hour.
So if you spin up a virtual
machine, you run it for, like,
20 minutes, and then
you shut it down,
you get charged
for an entire hour.
On Compute Engine, you only get
charged for those 20 minutes.
And then if you start it up
again and run it for another 15
minutes, then you only get
charged for those 15 minutes,
instead of it being
rounded up to an hour.
Now, we do have a
10-minute minimum.
So if you spin it up
for three minutes,
you get charged for 10 minutes.
But really, that's-- it's pretty
significant savings if what
you're doing with the VM doesn't
typically take on the order
of multiple hours.
And obviously, the longer the
VM runs, the less of an impact--
or less of a savings you get.
But that's where sustained
use discounts comes in,
which is the longer you run
the VM for a given month,
the cheaper that VM-- the
per hour, or per minute cost
of that VM is.
So if you run a VM 24/7
for an entire month,
you basically get,
like, 30% discount off
of the list price for
that entire month.
And we just kind of--
at the end of the month,
we aggregate all of your
VMs up and do the math
to basically give you
a discount over all
of the usage based on how long
those VMs ran for that month.
And that's all-- especially
the permanent billing, that's
really kind of
comes down to like
some of the flexible real-time
data processing infrastructure
that we have here
at Google that lets
us do near real-time
billing and monetization
like that, which is--
when you're talking
about the number of VMs
that GCE runs on behalf
of their customers, like doing
per minute billing for all
of those VMs all the time is
actually a pretty significant
data processing challenge.
But that's the type of thing
that Google is good at,
and so we've leveraged some
of that in-house expertise
to solve it.
Another of my favorite features
is custom machine types.
That's basically when you go
to create a VM, you typically
specify what's called an
instance type or a machine
type.
And that basically is
kind of the hardware spec,
like the virtual
hardware spec of the VM.
So it's the number of cores you
want, how much RAM you want.
And basically what
GCE offers that none
of the major competitors
offer is the ability
to customize that.
Like you know what, I
don't need eight cores.
But four cores is
too small, so I'm
going to create a six-core VM.
And I happen to know that
I need two gigs per core,
so I'm going to create a
six-core, 12 gigabyte of RAM
virtual machine using
custom machine types.
And that lets me save money
over the next highest up.
So actually, let me
take a quick step back.
Like, we also--
like GCE, as well as
the other major public
clouds, give you
a selection of predefined
instance types or machine
types.
So Google calls them,
like, N1 standard 1,
N1 high mem4, et cetera.
And the standard
high mem high CPU
really just refers to
the RAM-to-core ratio.
Competitors offer--
like AWS offers
the C34x large, C42x large,
et cetera, et cetera.
So there's these predefined
machine types that you get,
or that you have to choose from.
But if your workload
doesn't fit exactly
into-- like it's
too small for, like,
a C42x large but too small
for a C4x large-- or too big
for a C4x large, there's
no-- you basically
have to buy the
next size up, or you
have to figure out how to
tailor your workload so
that it fits exactly into one
of those predefined shapes.
And that's where custom
machine types really shines,
is the ability to tailor the
VM shape to the workload,
not vice versa.
And that's especially
important for enterprises
coming to the cloud,
because they've probably--
what they're probably running on
is, like, a Dell server that's
got some number of cores
and some amount of RAM,
and that's basically their
homogeneous fleet that they've
run-- they're running
right now for all
these different applications.
And instead of having to
kind of scratch their heads
and figure out how to adjust
the workload so that it fits
in with one of these
predefined types,
they just go create
a custom machine
type that exactly mimics
what they have on prem,
and they're off to the races.
It's one less kind of
pain point or friction
point in moving to GCE from an
existing on-prem environment.
MARK MANDEL: And that would
seem to me as well like a really
nice cost savings, as well.
I know-- I do some stuff
with gaming companies,
and so often they want, like,
necessarily a whole lot of RAM,
but they don't
necessarily need, like,
the fastest CPU in the world.
So when you're in that
sort of cookie-cutter world
and you have to have both
of those at the same time,
this is a nice way
to say, hey, no, we
don't need that much CPU,
that's fine, but lots of RAM.
So we can really
tailor-- spend our money
exactly where we need.
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: Yes.
Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There's-- one of the things--
you've been talking a lot about
the flexibility of
our infrastructure.
And one of the places
where I think it shows
is the fact that we're
able to [? reside ?]
precise persistent disks
while the instance is running
and the disk it attached to it.
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is something
that, the first time I
showed to a customer,
they were just
impressed with that.
It was like, is this magic?
How does that work?
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: Yeah.
That's funny.
That was something that we
launched fairly recently,
and I don't think it's-- don't
think it's really kind of hit
the kind of customer psyche,
or whatever you want to-- kind
of collective customer psyche,
because it is a super powerful
feature.
And the customers that
have encountered-- you
know, there's a
lot of issues that
happen that could cause your--
like especially like your root
boot partition to fill
up, like your boot PD.
Like typically, we
only allocate, like,
10 gigs' worth or
20 gigs' worth.
You keep those small, because
you don't put any data on them
and stuff like that.
But still, any-- most
guest OS dump, like,
all of their logging
information on there, et cetera.
And so if, for whatever reason,
you're not paying attention
and you don't have
any alerts set up
and the root volume
fills up with, like,
log data or something,
then all of a sudden
you're now no longer able
to SSH it into your VM,
because SSH relies on being
able to write its own logs.
And when that fails, like
everything fails, basically.
And this is like common--
not just on-- this
is basically any Linux,
any server that runs.
If you fill up the root
partition, bad things happen.
And this hot resize is just
a super easy and quick way
to be like, oh crap,
I had a runaway log
script or something, and
my volume's filled up.
Let me just go into the
UI, click two buttons,
and double the size of the
root PD volume so I can go in
and fix my spammy
log file, or fix
whatever it is that's filling
up the root partition.
Like it's just-- it's such
a convenient and powerful
mechanism.
And it's not just related
to root volumes, obviously.
Like if you've got data
volumes that-- let's say
you use GCS Connector to
pull a bunch of data from GCS
to a local VM to a bunch of
VMs, PDs to do a Hadoop job.
And you're writing
out the results,
and all of a sudden
the job fails
because the data disk that you
were writing out to is full.
You know what?
Like you just go
resize-- again, just
go resize the disk and rerun
the job, and all of a sudden
you're good to go.
You don't have to stop the VM.
You don't have to shut
everything down and detach it
and resize it, or create a
bigger one and copy everything.
It's just super, super powerful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You could even consider
doing that through the API.
So you don't need to even--
just click a single button.
Just everything happens.
It's just amazing.
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: Yeah.
Set up a Stackdriver
alert that automatic--
that triggers-- you
know, a Stackdriver alert
that, when it gets 90% full,
call a cloud function that
calls the GCE API that
resizes the disk up,
doubles the size of the disk.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So many
cloud things [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: I'm pretty
sure out teammate Terry
has a little script
that he can--
he demoed, showing off
doing exactly that.
Where it--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: --keeps track
of how much data you've got
and how much free
space you have.
And then if it runs
out, it's like, oh,
I'm going to double
your partition here.
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It'll be fine.
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG:
But you might
want to look at
this at some point
to figure out why
it's filling up.
But in the meantime, just go--
MARK MANDEL: In the
meantime, it's fine.
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: --fix it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And that's really cool.
And I think that touches
on some other stuff, too.
Like for example, we
can do a bunch of stuff
to your infrastructure
as it's running.
Like-- you want to talk a
little bit about live migrations
and how that works?
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG:
Yeah, sure.
So you know, the-- one of the
biggest challenges for a cloud
provider is keeping the software
and hardware infrastructure
that all the VMs run on,
keeping it up to date,
keeping it patched,
secure, rolling out
new versions of all
the different layers
of that stack, et cetera.
And you know, if it's something
significant like upgrading
the host kernel that is
running on the server
that your VMs are running
on, like obviously that's
a very disruptive action
for [AUDIO OUT] or anything
that's running on that host.
You basically have to, like,
take everything off the host.
What we call drain.
We have to drain the
host and do the upgrade,
and then reboot it.
And it comes up
on the new kernel.
That's all like-- and so
what-- with-- in that reality,
in the reality of
maintaining these systems
and keeping them all
up to date and patched,
what we've done for GCE is
built this technology called
Live Migration.
This is not like-- you know,
we didn't invent a technology.
Like VMware has been doing their
own version of Live Migration--
they call it vMotion--
for many years.
But we're, like, the first
public cloud hyperscale
provider to do live
migration at the scale
that we're doing live migration.
Like obviously, we run
lots and lots of VMs
across many, many zones.
And we use Live
Migration quite a bit
to make sure that all of
our underlying systems
are patched and updated, and
all without disrupting the VM.
So what a live
migration does is it
basically-- your VM is
running on one host machine.
And let's say we've got to
take that host machine offline
to do a host kernel upgrade.
So what we do is we trigger live
migrations for the VMs that are
running on that host machine.
And what a live migration does
is, while the VM is running,
it starts copying
the state over-- it
creates a new virtual machine
target on a different host,
starts copying all of the state,
like RAM, the specification
for the VM, the machine type,
all of the different PDs
and things like that,
network connections.
Basically, it creates an exact
mirror of that virtual machine
on a different host.
And then once we've copied
the majority of the state,
we pause the source
VM briefly, and then
unpause-- copy the rest
of the remaining state,
and then unpause
it on the target.
And now that VM is now running
on a different host machine
without any impact-- well, with
minor performance and a very
brief brownout-- a very
brief blackout window,
which is what we call that
pause period that it's actually
paused doing that
last transition in.
And you know, that--
for most applications,
that pause is
completely invisible.
And there is very little
performance degradation
for the majority of
our virtual machines.
And so most customers just
don't even-- their workloads
don't even notice
that we've done this.
And it's very, very
powerful compared
to the alternative, which is
essentially scheduling reboots
and, you know, oh, we need
to roll out a security patch
for like the latest Heartbleed
vulnerability or whatever.
And so that required
our competition
to reboot, like, a significant
chunk of their customers' VMs.
And so there was like this
huge flurry of activity
if you were a customer there
where you had to go basically
figure out when
the best time you
were going to be able to
reboot in the next few days,
because the machines that were
running on-- that your VMs were
running on were vulnerable.
And then Google
did the same thing.
We patched all of
our host machines.
But we did it all
using Live Migration,
so we didn't have to
require any reboots.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well that sounds like
super interesting stuff.
I have to ask this, though.
Feel free to dodge the answer.
I totally understand.
What sort of new features
could we possibly
be seeing for Compute Engine?
I know we had Next recently, and
we had a bunch of announcements
there.
But can you hint at anything?
Can you touch on anything?
I wouldn't be doing my
job if I didn't ask.
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG:
Yeah, sure.
I can talk in general terms.
Like so as you mentioned,
GCP, the most recent GCP
Next that we had down
in San Francisco,
we did talk about
the fact that we're
going to be adding
more regions and zones
over the next few years.
And so we are very
serious about continuing
to expand our footprint
across-- into more
regions that our
customers are asking for,
and that provide the locality
that different workloads
require.
And so the first two of those
areas that we're expanding to
is going to be Oregon and
Japan later this year.
And then obviously
in 2017, we're
going to be expanding into
even more areas, more regions.
So we'll be opening up
new regions and zones.
And that's going to be a
huge benefit to customers
so that they can run
their workloads where
it makes the most sense and
is where the-- near where
their users happen to be.
So that's one of the big
things that we're doing
over the next couple years.
And without getting
too specific,
we are also working on
features that make it easier
to troubleshoot your VMs.
You know, kind of like
that hot grow PD thing
that we talked about.
Like if something goes
wrong with the VM when
it's booting up, like it's
often very challenging
to figure out what went wrong.
And so we're working on tools
to make that a lot easier.
Again, think the
hot grow analogy
where I just click a few buttons
or call an API and it's solved.
This is somewhat similar.
Like, you try to
make it as simple
as possible to figure
out what went wrong
and fix it without having to do
the whole dance of, you know,
deleting the VM, without
deleting the disk,
attaching the disk
to another VM,
figuring out what's the
problem, and basically there's
this whole sequence.
It's a real pain right now, and
we want to make that easier.
And then also another
thing we're working on
are kind of more
enterprise-friendly pricing
and usage models.
You know, enterprises have quite
a huge spectrum of requirements
when it comes to how
they do budgeting
and how they figure
out what they're
going to spend their
money, their budgets on,
and that sort of thing.
And so more enterprise-friendly
pricing models
are definitely something
that we're working on
to be able to make it
easier for more enterprises
to easily shift stuff
over to cloud platform.
And then obviously, we
continue doing the-- like
turning the crank on the bigger,
faster, cheaper computing.
So those are in general terms.
And if you're-- anybody out
there who's evaluating GCE
or GCP in general and you
want to hear more about some
specific details, please
reach out to me on Twitter,
and we can have a much more
low-level chat and much more
detailed chat under NDA.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, I think we're pretty
much running out of time,
but is there anything else
that you would like to mention?
Some topics that we
might have missed?
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: I
think the biggest thing
that I want to make sure--
if I could send everyone away
with one to-do or one
action, I would say check
out cloud.google.com
if you haven't yet.
If this is the first time you're
hearing that Google has a cloud
platform-- hopefully
not, because you've
got some regular
podcast subscribers,
and so people are familiar
with it, but tell your friends.
Check out our website.
There's a ton of
amazing products
that we have-- data and
analytics, machine learning,
your basic GCE, your App Engine,
which is just write your code
and deploy it and forget
about it, and pretty much
everything in between.
And it's a very
comprehensive platform,
and we're really,
really pleased to see
the growth that we're seeing.
But we would love it if we--
we always love more customers,
and so please check it out.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Well thank you very much
for joining us, Scott.
It was an absolute
pleasure to talk to you.
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG:
Yeah, it was great
talking with you guys, too.
Thanks for having me again.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks again
to Scott Van Woudenberg for such
an interesting conversation.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I really enjoyed it.
It's good to see
people still talking
about the basic building
blocks of the cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Virtual machines
are a real thing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Even though
they're called virtual.
So yeah, very interesting.
Let us know if you
have any questions.
We have the contact information
for Scott on the show notes.
And apparently, he's very
keen on getting your questions
and opinions.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And we're always looking for
more questions of the week,
too, so you know--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Absolutely.
Yes.
And talking about
questions of the week,
let's go with a
question of the week
that this-- for this episode
come from Noam Franco.
And he says, hi,
Francesc and Mark.
It's a great podcast you have.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you very much.
And basically he says he
listened to the episode
on Humble Bundle.
And we mentioned--
so Andy [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned, that
they were backing up
Datastore to BigQuery
via Google Cloud Storage.
And he's basically asking
what is this magic?
How does this work?
MARK MANDEL: Right.
So I had to look into this.
It's actually kind
of interesting.
There have been ways to back
up Datastore for a long time.
A lot of them have
been fairly manual.
So we've got some links
to the show notes.
There is a way you can go in
and enable the Datastore Admin,
and then go from there to back
up all of your Datastore data
in one big go.
There's no incremental
backup, but you
can take the whole
thing and say, OK, I
want these particular
kinds within Datastore,
and then just put those
in a storage bucket.
And from there, once you've got
that, it's relatively trivial
to be able to point at that
Datastore backup inside Cloud
Storage and say, hey, BigQuery
can you ingest this, please?
One of the cool things
to note is that you
can do scheduled backups.
They are full backups,
though, so keep that in mind
if it's like your
quotas and how much you
want to be reading and
writing for your Datastore.
So you can do it with a Cron
from-- specifying a Cron
file on App Engine.
Like, you can totally do that.
It's a little bit of
custom code, yeah,
but you can get that up
and running, depending
on how often you want to
be doing these full backups
of this data.
But yeah, then you can
take those backups,
you can ingest
those into BigQuery,
either through the admin
or through the API,
and then you can access
that data from BigQuery
and do your analytics and
all that sort of fun stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Nothing really fancy, really.
Just a bunch of
things that you need
to plug one to each other, and
then everything just works.
MARK MANDEL: Everything
should just work.
So yeah, I mean like the
admin will create jobs for you
and run through task queues
and all this sort of stuff
in the background.
It's worth noting, like I
said, it's not incremental.
It's full backups.
So if, for example, you're
getting multiple kinds,
they could be out of
sync a little bit.
So you know, it's not going
to take a complete snapshot.
So you sort of have to
take that into account.
But for stuff you're
porting to BigQuery,
I'm thinking that's
probably less important.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I guess that if you
really wanted something
that could do it weekly or
daily or something like that,
you can always build your own
thing that could generate that.
Like, it could just create
just a query of all the data
that was created during
the last day or so.
But you're going to have
to do more manual things.
If you-- everything you're
going to do is the whole thing
and just dump the whole
thing onto BigQuery,
sounds like a good idea.
MARK MANDEL: In some
cases, this also
could push towards,
like, a good argument
for using things like PubSub.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: So that when
you go to store your data,
it goes through your data, but
another subscriber maybe picks
that data up, shoves it
off into BigQuery as well,
and then you can keep
that data alive in there
and have multiple things do
stuff based on those actions.
And PubSub is a really
great fit for that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, absolutely.
Cool.
So before we
finish, why don't we
discuss-- why don't we
talk about our next plans?
What are you going to be doing?
MARK MANDEL: What am
I going to be doing?
So this week, we
still have Change
the Game here in San Francisco.
Very excited for that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
What day is that?
MARK MANDEL: That is a game
conference we are running here
in San Francisco.
We're going have a bunch
of customers come by,
some Googlers.
I am co-presenting
twice, so I guess
that means I'm doing
one presentation.
So talking about
multiplayer games,
analytics for games,
all sorts of cool stuff.
It's going to be a
really fun event.
I know there's going to be
a bunch of Googlers around,
as well.
I will be there, which
I'm sure just makes it
extra, extra special.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I really like
that my question was actually
what day is that, but
you don't understand me.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
what day is that.
I'm sorry.
I thought you said
what's going on there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No,
no, no, what day.
What day.
What "die."
What "die" is that?
MARK MANDEL: That is on Friday--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, cool.
MARK MANDEL: --so it'll
be a couple of days
after the podcast comes out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
After that, I'll be
presenting at GDG Twin
Cities for their meetup.
I'll be at Open Source North.
I'll be at Dev Objective.
And then I'll be in New York for
a gaming panel towards the end
the month.
I haven't got all the
details of that yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I'm doing
some travel this month.
It's pretty crazy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Busy month.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And then I'm taking
a little break
and spending a weekend
in New York, because--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: --why not.
I know you're preparing
for your long biking ride.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
I'm going to be biking from
San Francisco to Los Angeles.
And I'm leaving on Sunday.
So next week, I'm going to
spend my whole week on a bike.
Very excited.
[LAUGHTER]
Very excited, slightly scared.
But I think it's
going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: Based on
your level of sunburn,
it looks like you're
well-prepared.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah.
That was from yesterday, yeah.
Yeah and after that, I'm
going to be taking a couple
weeks off, relaxing and writing
stuff and trying to be more
productive without traveling.
And after that, I
will go to GopherCon.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But that is in July, so we have
a couple weeks of recording
podcasts before that.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, thank you
so much for joining me today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, thank
you so much for joining me,
as well, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: I'll
speak to you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]